hey what's up guys it's Marcus Bramley
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD unboxing video and this is actually
another d s international unboxing video
and the thing is it's kind of like a
surprise unboxing video because I've
never seen this product before one of
the people from D s international
contacted me and asked would you be
ready to test a wireless flexible
multimedia enabled keyboard and let me
know if you're ready and I said yeah
that sounds like a good idea I think I
can do that so I've never seen those
three things combined into one keyboard
before so it'll be nice a nice change of
pace something to look at so I'm just
gonna go ahead and open up the box here
this is going to be our first
impressions and our fiha basically just
our first impressions of the product now
keep in mind this is a brand new product
you're probably gonna be the first to
see this guys before the link goes up to
the D s international website so let's
just get right into it here we go
looks like we got a whole lot of peanuts
in here but see if we can get through
those just by pull those out I'm gonna
have to clean up the peanuts afterwards
actually it wasn't so bad so here is
said keyboard and nothing really else in
the box so I'm just gonna go ahead and
move that out the way sorry about that
so here it is and there's still a few
more packing peanuts in there which I'll
move out of the way of course but it's
actually what is it wrapped up I'm not
even sure quite yet what its gonna be so
let's get right into the unboxing just
unwrap this from the bubble wrap or
whatever and it comes in a tube this is
interesting I've never seen something
like this before so it says flexible
keyboard I hold that up to the camera
right there it says flexible keyboard
and it does look pretty well that's it's
got a few interesting features so this
is connect to a ps2 adapter and go ahead
and throw that in USB alright and what
is it waterproof and spill proof and
very portable I'm just gonna go ahead
and get right into this go ahead and
open it up and just show you guys
exactly
you know how flexible it is how portable
this keyboard really is so here we go
now take the top off right there I don't
really need the knife anymore here we go
and looks like it just comes right out
it's actually very rubbery this is very
interesting
it's very rubbery keyboard and it's
definitely if it can fit in a package
this size it's definitely going to be
portable much more portable than your
average multimedia keyboard and yeah so
just taking this out right here I'm
gonna see how it connects to our
computer so here's a little thing that
came in and here is the keyboard you
guys Wow wow that is cool so here's the
keyboard itself over here we have what
looks like yeah you just tap that to
connect this is our 2.4 gigahertz
wireless connection right here
wow that's very Wow that's that's
actually it's pretty surprising that it
they can fit a keyboard this size and
all the you can see all the electronics
in the back of it if you if you look
closely enough I'll show you all that in
the review video but I mean this is very
cool you go ahead and tap to connect and
you'll probably have yep here you go in
this packet over here to the side they
give you another flexible sort of
adapter and you go ahead and tap that to
connect so that matches up just fine
with that and they also give you
instruction manual obviously a wireless
you know wireless keyboard has an
instruction manual I'm not really a big
instructions guy but they definitely
tell you how to use it here's your your
installation CD a mini CD of course
because everything's portable with these
but this will work in your regular CD
drive so that's cool and you get your
triple-a batteries these two triple A
batteries which I'm guessing will go in
the keyboard itself so it's pretty cool
um I'm gonna go ahead and read the
instructions manual to find out where
the Triple A batteries go yet actually
supposed to slide this off right here oh
uh so yeah here's here's where the
batteries go right inside there and you
close it up right there and press to
connect
and here's your wireless keyboard so
yeah it's definitely the most portable
keyboard I've ever seen I will
definitely get you guys with your review
video just how nicely it types whether
everything works and just how portable
it really is whether I can fit it in a
laptop bag or something so thank you for
watching the unboxing video I hope you
liked it and stay tuned for the review
video in one two three weeks guys this
is really cool that yes international
was able to send this out to me and
thanks for watching guys peace